[Music]
let's go out to Danville Illinois and
talk
to Jane what's up Jane hey what's up
party and what are you
doing uh sitting here chatting with you
I have a question okay what's up uh okay
so one morning I was listening to your
podcast and you said we marry our
unfinished
business and I have never heard anyone
say that before and I was wondering if
you could explain what that means oh
yeah I would love to that's a great
question um so I I don't even remember
when I said that I've probably said that
multiple times on this show
um some would go as far as to say it is
a uh nervous system wiring that it's
it's that deeply embedded in you um but
I know it's it's common vernacular among
therapists particularly relationship
therapists and here's the
idea let's say um you're a little girl
let's do this let's make you the example
can we make you the example Jane sure
okay uh tell me about how you grew up
tell me about your
dad okay I didn't meet my dad until I
was in my 30s
okay what happened where'd he
go uh I don't know um I met him uh well
I flew out to Colorado me him and
uh then he came back to Illinois to
visit for a little bit no no why did he
leave you in the first place why did a
husband like a why did a dad abandon the
most precious thing on planet Earth
which is a little
girl what I was told from my mom um was
that when she told him that she was
pregnant he left okay um so I never knew
him my whole life um my aunt found a
newspaper clipping um and she sent it to
me when I was in my 30s and Saidi think
these are your grandparents and so I
looked them up they live in the same
Hometown that I grew up in I don't live
in that Hometown anymore um and so found
him got in touch with him things were
great uh flew out to Colorado met him um
and then you know I came back home
obviously and then he came for a visit
to Illinois and and we like exchanged
letters and he would send gifts for me
and my husband and my kids and things
like that and that went on for a little
while and then he started I don't know
it was really weird like he would he
wanted to come and visit me but he would
call me and ask me questions about my
mom and then he would call my mom and
ask her questions about
me and she told him you know if you're
just coming to get with me then stay
where you're at but if you're coming to
see Jane then I'll you know absolutely
come and visit her and he was coming to
visit me but he would call me and ask me
if he would be okay to stay with my mom
so it was like really weird um so when
she told him that he never contacted me
ever again and so I haven't heard from
him since and I'm fine with that
um okay I've lived 30 years without him
I've not you know I don't think about it
anymore um I figure you know I found out
what I needed to know about my past on
his side of the family okay I did meet
my grandparents they were wonderful
people um and I'm just really grateful
that I grew up with my mom and her
parents and not the other way around so
awesome so tell me about tell me about
your mom much of it uh my mom she's well
she just passed away um a little over a
year ago uh in April it be two years and
um
she oh gosh she had three kids by three
different people um she was married but
the people that she was married to was
not the fathers of any of us um so did
you have did you have a household of of
stepdads uh not a whole lot um maybe
like two or three um one of them wasn't
for very long um mainly we grew up my
mom lived with her parents so like my
entire life until I moved out for
college I lived with my grandparents and
my mom
okay so I I'm gonna take a wild
just um these kind of statements like
you mirror your unfinished business
those aren't um always etched in
concrete okay MH but it would not be
uncommon for someone who had experienced
the life you experienced and I want to
be real clear to The Listener Jane like
can you and I just talk like super no
one's listening to us except for a
couple million people is that cool real
quick just a private to the side yeah
you gave me the very sanitized version
of your childhood Fair yes very
sanitized yeah very very sanitized okay
so it would not be uncommon
for someone who grew up in the home that
you grew up
in to very much be a
pursuer and a people pleaser someone who
made sure everybody else was okay oh
yeah that's me 100% okay so when I say
you marry your unfinished
business the sentiment is your nervous
system not your not this isn't a
character issue or what your
body is asking what was so bad about me
that that guy
left all those years
ago right what was so bad about me that
stepdad a came in for just a little bit
and hung out with me and then took off
is I not good enough for him
either and then what happens is your
body asks that question over and over
and over and over and over again what
about me what is so bad about me
and you start to solve that
problem I will be nobody will
have any uh sweat on their glasses I'm
going to wipe it all off everyone's
going to have a meal in front of them
the laundry is going to be done I am
going to be and what without thinking it
without meaning to you find yourself in
another romantic relationship where
you're
chasing and you end up trying to to
prove yourself to somebody else and to
somebody else and to somebody else no no
no I'm worth it I'm worth it I promise
I'm worth it I promise I'm worth
it okay and so that doesn't mean that's
who you end up with over time that
doesn't mean that that plays its way out
in every
situation but if you Jane have found
yourself exhausted in marriage over the
last 15 20 30
years or you've got kids now that you
love you love your husband but not one
person has ever asked Jane what do you
want to
do then there might be worth asking have
you spent your adult life trying to make
sure that nobody ever leaves you again
even if that cost you the things that
you are really interested in the big
curious questions about how the universe
worked that you wanted to pursue but you
were too busy making sure everybody else
could pursue them
and that may not be you I don't want to
cast that on you but I'm just using you
as an example of that would be marrying
your unfinish business and sometimes you
marry somebody who's amazing and he'll
never
leave often people who went through what
you went through as a kid are on
marriage number
four because they marry people who leave
and they try so desperately to solve
that and they can't because it was never
their problem to begin with your dad
left because something was wrong with
that dude not
you
yeah how's that ringing
true
uh the the husband part I'm he's my
first husband um we've been married for
28 years and oh 29 years we just had an
anniversary in November congratulations
and um thank you and um but the people
please definitely that is 100% me I'm
I'm very much a people pleaser I will
I'll apologize for things that just to
keep the peace there you go like yeah
um but yeah
like I know my sister and I have
different views on the way we see my mom
as we grew up um so I don't know I'm
just always like trying to see the
positive of things and here's the deal
you're probably both right by the way y
are proba both right yeah we are because
I agree with what she says um but I I
guess I just choose to see the positive
and not dwell on the negative and what I
would tell you is when I say something
like uh your body
knows you go looking every day for the
most positive attributes your mom has
cuz why not right why not what is just
at this stage in the game what is
revisiting all this ugly going to do
right right let's find the positive and
let's let's sit on
that there's some real value in that but
you have to honor both sides of the
Ledger because your body is still trying
to protect you all the
time so if your mom was
unstable yet she showed up and provided
if your mom paraded a bunch of unsafe
men through your house through a
household of little
girls but man we never missed a freaking
meal both things are true
and there's some safety in that where
you exhale and drop your shoulders and
you're like ah I'm never going to miss a
meal with her the heat is never going to
get turned off because she works her
butt off she'll do whatever it takes and
there's a high alert in your nervous
system waiting for who's coming in the
door
next or in your case who's going to
leave
next I do get very um I know my kids
have pointed out to me a lot that I get
very uh judgmental okay when or not
judgmental but defensive when somebody
judges me I get very very defensive
because that's all you
got because if you're found to be less
than boom now they have reason to go
which is your body's worst possible
fear it sounds like you did not marry
your unfinished business so kudos to you
did you marry an amazing guy that's good
huh did you marry an amazing
yes awesome I he's not perfect but I'm
not perfect so I mean I am so I mean
y'all two of course none of us are right
none of us are no of course but no he's
he's a great husband great father
awesome the idea so hey great great
question the idea of marrying your
unfinished business is those core issues
that came up when we were
kids why did you
leave how did I make you so angry that
you had to hit me that
much why was my why was Perfection why
were my grades and how nice my bed was
made why was that more important than
you hugging
me those things get wired into us and we
go looking to solve that problem down
the
road and I'll keep saying this to I'm
blue in the face that problem is never
the kid it's always the adult in the
room and then we often
crash into a spouse and our body goes ah
this one feels familiar I'll solve this
one this guy's really aggressive and I
see how angry he is but I'm gonna be so
loving he won't hit
me I'm gonna fix this Cosmic Loop and
then
bam I'm gonna this guy he's I could tell
man I could feel it he leaves He Cheats
he's not going to cheat on me I'm going
to be the most perfect wife who ever
existed my dad cheated on my mom my
granddad cheated on my grandmother it
stops with me and that dude goes and
cheats
too cuz your body's solving for
homeostasis and safety all the time and
those two things
Collide great great question Jane thank
you so so much I want to tell you man
I'm proud of
you because for sanitizers as you told
that you grew up in a really tough tough
environment and it sounds like of course
you're not perfect but it sounds like
you stood in front of the fire and
you've changed things for your family
you've got a steady marriage over 30
years you got grown kids I'm proud of
you you've given your kids a chance to
continue to change that Legacy into
something that's going to be beautiful
you planted seeds to trees you're never
going to get to eat the fruit of I'm
proud of you
Jane